[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america we're so glad you're here as we
talk about your life and your money we
talk about helping people build wealth
doing work that they love and create
actual
amazing relationships the phone number
is triple eight eight two five
five two two five jacob's going to start
this hour off in fargo north dakota hi
jacob welcome to the ramsey show
hello mr ramsey it's a pleasure to meet
you how are you doing better than i
deserve sir how can i help
great so i'm a 20 year old college
student and i recently finished my
sophomore year of college and i'm
currently studying to become a nurse i
have roughly two years left in my
program and i'll be able to graduate
debt free in 2024. good for you in
addition to that yeah thank you in
addition to that i currently work as a
cna at a large hospital in the fargo
area and i was recently approached by my
manager who came up with an offer for me
and she presented an offer where i would
be able to work at this hospital for
three years after graduation
in addition to that i will receive a
thirty thousand dollar sign-on bonus um
given that i'm only halfway through this
program i'm a little hesitant at the
moment to take this offer but i'm
curious if this is something i should
entertain
so the only advantage to you is thirty
thousand bucks
correct and i've had a really strong
working relationship with this hospital
and i do enjoy working at this hospital
[Music]
okay have you looked at options in your
area for other hospitals and what the
pay would be
i have a little bit um currently this
hospital pays about two dollars less an
hour than other hospitals um but it's
it's a very good starting wage for
nurses in this area um in this part of
the country so it's i consider it to be
competitive
okay
well i i'm kind of with you
number one let's just establish nursing
incredible career path
and as long as i've been doing this show
for 30 years there's been a shortage of
nurses
correct so you've always been able to
land a job
you know and lots of different kinds of
jobs actually within the nursing field
and so a lot of flexibility always a
need for you that kind of thing so if
that's kind of our baseline
then off of that
i don't think i'm tying up
uh
myself
you don't need the money
you've got you've got a way to work your
way through school with no debt you told
us that way to go good job
and um and so the money's just kind of
gravy on the biscuit it'd be nice but
you know it's not like
it's not like oh i cannot have to borrow
student loans if i do this uh i might
think about it then
but in this case you got your way mapped
out to go all the way through and then
you're a free agent upon graduation
i'll bet you could get more than 30 000
at that point
true yeah
and that's that's the part that i'm
struggling with is it's really hard to
predict what would be out there in two
years if we're at a peak now if this is
a good time to take an offer but i i i
don't understand i think i think
there'll be a you know again i'm going
to say i'm going to establish the fact
in my mind anyway anecdotally i don't
have research to back it up but
that there's pretty much always a
shortage of nurses
and so that means that you will be able
to land something
and probably something with a signing
bonus i wouldn't doubt it a bit
so um i kind of think that offer or
better might be on the table at
graduation
i might be wrong we're gambling what's
the harm in waiting until graduation 30
000 bucks if they won't if they don't
have any more you know yeah
you miss out on that if if we're wrong
right if it's off the table
um but the way i answer questions on
this show is if i woke up in your shoes
what would i do
i'm uh i'm going to bet that there's
going gonna be as good a deal or better
on uh uh on the table and i'm gonna say
thanks
uh let's talk as i get a little bit
closer to graduation
okay that's the advice i needed to hear
so thank you so much thank you brother
appreciate you calling man i got to tell
you george these uh
this is the sharpest bunch of 20 year
olds i run in they're everywhere of
course they call i'll call this show and
you know my gosh i mean his question
written out but yeah you know but still
it's gives me hope yeah it's pretty
impressive people actually want to work
out there when i was 20 nobody's
offering me a signing bonus i'm just
saying okay i'm just just saying all
right all right aj is with us
for good reason hey jason austin texas
hey aj what's up
hey dave uh george thank you guys so
much for having me on today i really
really appreciate it sure how can we
help um
well i'm calling i just started a
financial piece me and my wife started
financial peace university about three
or four weeks ago
we're on baby step number two it has
been absolutely great good um
you know we're still working on trying
to get our budget
uh figured out and how that actually
works so i'm working with the instructor
there to try to help
with uh helping us understand it a
little bit more but the reason for my
call is i got a call today from a
company called adr
alternative dispute resolution center
and they said told they said that you
know they were they were going to be
their legal courier and they were going
to be delivering papers to me
uh tomorrow okay uh explaining that
we
had a judgment against us from bank of
america saying that we owed them
uh 1 263
and it was from they said overdraft fee
from 2007. does that sound like
something that happened i vaguely
remember to be honest with you
uh but i guess it is somewhat possible
did you have a bank account with bank of
america in 2007
i'm not sure but i i think i may have
it's been so long ago obviously it was
obviously very if i did it was very
briefly
it was very brief
in regards to having it but i guess i'm
calling what is going on in your life in
2007 that you can't remember who your
bank was
well i had uh recently just got uh
drafted i remember i had gotten drafted
um to play ball
and um oh you were paying attention to
nothing okay except i wasn't paying
attention
now that makes sense that makes sense
all right so you think there's a at
least a reasonable possibility that you
open an account with them and that these
overdraft charges might be true
yes sir okay so well when they deliver
it tomorrow if they really do that's
probably bs
but when they deliver it tomorrow call
them up and offer them a settlement
well the guy told me on the phone today
he said that once they deliver the
paperwork he said that i can no longer
call them in order to negotiate they
said i'd have to go to
i guess whoever the
company is here or the court and we can
do that before them that's fine
that's fine go to them
because i'm saying this isn't going to
be delivered
okay
i'm saying this guy's lying
okay i may be wrong i may be wrong but
what's the worst case scenario uh they
deliver the papers and then you call the
new people and negotiate with them
whoever it is if you have a bill
outstanding from 2007 wants some money
and they would love to settle with you
they'd love to take 500 bucks and make
this go away you got a little money
store it up you could come up with 4 500
bucks and make this go away
yes sir good well don't negotiate with a
dude on the phone and don't give them
access to your checking account either
under any circumstances if you settle a
debt no access to your checking account
to settle it and you must have it in
writing to the settled amount settles
the debt in full it can be an email
that's fine but no electronic access to
your checking account george is right
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchhillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
imagine the energy of a jam-packed arena
filled with people ready to experience
what it means to have
life to the fullest picture all your
favorite speakers together on one stage
giving you the tools and the principles
that will create unstoppable momentum in
your life well that is smart conference
yep smart conference is back it's been
three years we're so pumped to get the
event back on the road in dallas that's
right dallas we're headed your way on
saturday october the 22nd it's all of
the ramsey personalities and we'll be
speaking of course on money on personal
growth leadership mental health
relationships career and our friends
pastor craig and amy grochelle from life
church are coming they're gonna speak on
marriage
it's gonna be incredible you won't want
to miss this dallas tickets are only 39
dollars for a whole day and at the end
of the day you will leave smart
it's the smart conference you're gonna
love it hey i'm serious this is a blast
we should charge 339 for this lineup
um
all of the ramsey personalities on the
lineup it is going to be a full day get
your tickets now at ramseysolutions.com
events and george we will be in orlando
a week from thursday we're doing our
last building wealth event of the spring
and then we've got four events in the
fall but orlando may 19th if you still
want tickets they're only 25
a four pack if you want to bring some
friends for 60 bucks that's 15 bucks a
ticket you can't buy a pizza for that so
uh come on out we'll be in orlando one
week from thursday may the 19th and that
building wealth in las vegas the other
night was a lot of fun if orlando's
anything like vegas we are in for a good
time the people there were amazing there
was a lot of people who didn't even know
they were like this is my first thing
with ramsay ever and it was amazing
there's people who are long-time fans of
ours who have done all the baby steps
and it was just encouraging to be with
real people who wanted to transform
their life so that's what these are
events are about
you know in the building wealth event
one of the things we talk about is that
when you get
desperate
afraid
or angry
the
higher thinking parts of your brain shut
down
and you don't make
good decisions so i have found in my
life once i get if i get greedy
if i get
afraid if i get desperate right after
that i get stupid
and right after i get stupid i get broke
er
and so that's what's happening in the
housing market right now
because oh god the house prices are up
and oh god the interest rates went up
and oh god i'm never gonna be able to
get a house
oh god and once your brain starts doing
that you're getting ready to do
something stupid party's over there's
gonna be a lot of regret and they call
into this show and go dave i did
something stupid dave help me so where
were you three years ago when i was
doing something stupid i was sitting
right here that's where i've been from
there let's find the moves
and i'm still telling you the same
things
about money because these principles
that we teach are timeless now we teach
people to get out of that and stay out
of that when it comes to a house it's
the only debt we don't yell at you for
we always have told you and we still
will tell you
even with the house price is so high
to get a 15-year
fixed rate
where the payment is no more than a
fourth of your take-home pay now why do
we do that just because we're killjoys
kind just because we don't want life to
be good for you
no we do that because we love you
we care about your financial future more
than that banker does more than the
mortgage companies do we're not making
money off of this off of the you getting
a mortgage or not getting a mortgage or
you getting a house or not getting a
house it's okay
we're okay
you're okay
but here's the thing
if you get in crazy mode because of
what's going on out there
you're going to buy too much house
you're going to put it on a 30-year
and you're going to be stuck in the
middle class or lower middle-class loop
all in the name of buying a house
because buying a house is financially
smart if i can't get one now i'll never
go well they're throwing money away dave
they're throwing money away on rent
that's the argument calm down it sounds
like a weather forecaster when there's a
tornado warning that's the way your
brain sounds oh god you know that's
their super bowl that's where they get
to create all the fear oh man
so yeah that's that and when your brain
is doing that
and so you know and people do it when
you know the first time i ever heard it
was like okay i live in california math
doesn't work in california well we kind
of know that but yes it does for
different reasons a lot of psychedelic
drugs involved in this but yes it does
work yeah
so here's the thing speaking of
california math
cbs news is reporting one of the biggest
hurdles in buying a home is coming up
with a hefty down payment
california
has a new program to end quotes help
first time home buyers jump that hurdle
what do you think george
oh boy keep reading you got it
california's forgivable equity builder
loan allows first-time home buyers who
have enough income for a monthly
mortgage payment to borrow up to 10 of a
home's purchase price to buy a house
outright the loan has an interest rate
of zero percent but borrowers who don't
occupy the home for at least five years
may have to repay the loan
what a concept so you can borrow your
down payment
at zero percent from california the new
effort comes as real estate prices have
hit record highs
in california and rising interest rates
have pushed
monthly payments
up hundreds of dollars
this is the way people's brains sound
i'm telling you i know exactly how your
brain sounds
because this is how mine sounds right
before i do some stupid butt stuff
it sounds like a beagle chasing a rabbit
is that what it sounds like i don't know
something like that but i mean your
brain your brain is shutting down but a
standard down payment of 20 for a home
in california could cost upwards of a
hundred thousand dollars well no kidding
that's the thing if you get a million
dollar home and they're letting you
borrow up to ten percent at zero percent
interest so letting you borrow a hundred
grand you still then have to go get a
nine hundred thousand dollar mortgage
and that's if your income qualifies
that's assuming you qualify but here's
the problem okay
you can't look out there five years in
the future
and know what stupid butt stuff the
state of california is going to do that
makes you want to leave
and you can't leave because then you
have to repay that loan
today today here is the thing
so even crazy people that believe in
debt are saying don't do it aren't they
george yeah oh yeah credit karma came
out and said this is probably a bad idea
if credit karma is saying don't borrow
the money
this tells you don't borrow the money i
mean this is like daniel's telling you
not to drink bourbon okay i mean that's
it's some bad bourbon right it's got to
be bad oh my god and i looked into this
your income has to be less than 80
percent of the area
median income
and so they're saying if you're broke
enough you can then afford all of this
and like i said with the numbers housing
in california not cheap so even with the
borrowed money they're allowing people
to borrow way more to get into homes
they can't afford okay so these are less
than 80 so you're eight eight tenths of
the median the middle income of the area
so this is um
middle income or lower middle income
people only that are going to get in
this trap
yeah which are the people that can't get
a house oh god you gotta get ass
listen i'm making fun of you because i
know how your brain sounds i know that
some of you have a valid concern about
buying a home in this market it's scary
out there house prices have shot up like
crazy
all the indications of all the data from
the industry is it's going to calm down
no it's not going to come down it's
going to calm down and data that george
and i saw in a meeting yesterday was
that uh
in 2020 house prices went up 32 percent
uh in 21 they went up what was 18 and i
was uh 14 i think okay and they're
expecting them this year to go up seven
percent so it's slowing down so the rate
of in and the average house price year
is about four percent okay over the last
25 30 years so we've had this huge spike
post pandemic the spike is tapering off
there will continue to be a an
appreciation an increase in value but it
will be a more reasonable and no you're
not going to get priced out of the
market if you continue to grow your
career you continue to manage money well
are you going to buy a house right now
probably not you might be too broke to
buy a house right now you might be too
broke to buy a car right now you might
be too broke to go on vacation right now
so don't do it
but dave i got to live my life yeah yolo
baby yolo
i'm serious it all this stuff is
temporary
and so calm your butt down
don't use the emotions
of the current
inflationary cycle
to uh cause you to dive off the deep end
into a pool with no water it's just
don't do it
don't
do it calm
down
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt-free stage david
and sarah are with us hey guys how are
you we're doing great dave how are you
doing better than i deserve welcome so
good to have y'all so how much debt have
you paid off we paid off 187 000
in two years and eight months good for
you good for you and your range of
income uh range starting when we
actually got intense and started
eliminating the debt uh 150 000
and then about halfway through we had
our first uh child and at that point
sarah stopped working
went down to about a hundred
and then she's been able to work
part-time from home so we're back up to
about 110 at this excellent good
okay and where are you guys from uh
we're here from fayetteville north
carolina oh very cool very cool and what
was the 197 000 in debt so 12 000 was a
car
um 75 000 was student loans and the
remaining hundred thousand was our house
we paid off time
we are weird and we are happy about it i
love it
way to go guys all right what's this
house worth uh so conservative estimate
would be about 165 at this point fine
fine very cool
very cool and uh oh my goodness how old
are you two uh i'm 30. i'm 29. and you
have a paid for house we do
wow we do
that is whacked
you don't have any 30 year old friends
that have paid for houses
not that i am aware of i like to think
of george as my friend but there we go
there we go this is good dave is
starting to trend here like this
i'm really impressed with you guys what
made you out of curiosity go you know
what we're not going to just tackle the
car loan and the student loan we're just
gonna keep plowing through to the
mortgage
uh are you just that weird i would say
it took a little while to get to that
point
starting all the way back at the
beginning i
i grew up uh with with your plan and uh
a huge fan of the show for a long time
um and i didn't didn't have any debt um
but then coming in to
to the marriage i had never actually had
the opportunity to practice the
principles and then and then i had to
come and tell him that i had student
loans um during marriage counseling
which i thought he knew but apparently
he had no idea that's what marriage
counseling is for that's true precisely
yeah for pre marriage counseling that's
right correct um so anyway i just
remember telling him and thinking like
oh he might be kind of
disappointed or whatever but he his face
just lit up and he was like i get to
practice what i believe
you were just so excited the way he
phrased that he was so happy yeah he had
the opportunity to experience
debt wow that's exactly right um so
once we were done with uh
your car loan also sarah
so we actually
it's a longer story than this but when
we moved so he's in the air force and so
when we changed stations i actually got
a job before him and so bought a vehicle
for my parents but we didn't have the
money to pay for it all at that time so
they were gracious enough to allow us to
have the vehicle and then pay them back
and install they were gracious enough to
get you further into debt that's sure
all right so 12 075 000 comes with a
package that's right all right cool and
then so you get married and it's just
both of you are talking about this and
you find out sarah that you've married
this guy who's thinks this is fun i mean
how sick is he really pretty sick i do
remember another funny story i came home
when we were living separately because i
got a job and he was still we were in
california before and then moved to
north carolina um and i came back to
visit and he had your book like with him
in his bed and i was like what are you
doing
while i'm gone for exact words where to
stop sleeping with david
[Laughter]
all right game on we're gonna pay this
thing off that's exactly right um yeah
basically back to your original question
how long y'all been married we've been
married almost four years four years
next week okay yep yep wow thank you for
your service what are you doing there
for thank you for your support uh i'm a
nurse in the air force excellent
excellent cool good good work
all right and now we're done housing
everything right
so um
now you've officially not only uh
studied the theory but have actually
experienced it david that's right and uh
sarah uh having done both as well now
what do you tell people i mean you're 30
years old you have paid for a house
that's weird what do you
how do you do that that's when that's
what they want to know right
yeah so i would say the biggest thing
that i've learned is just um learning to
be content with less
so i remember very vividly like starting
my career because our when we got
married timed out to when i finished
school so um i like quickly learned
like now i have a discretionary income
i've never had that before and what that
looked like and how to kind of use that
money
in a way that we wanted to and felt like
was honorable and so
quickly i learned though that you know
these goals that we had and that david
kind of taught me about um aren't normal
so they're not that's why we call you
weird that's right exactly and so
for me it was a big learning experience
of just being able to feel content and
yeah just be happy in what we did have
and being thankful for you know what the
lord has blessed us with and
being okay with not having the nicest
car in the parking lot the nicest house
um
so yeah i would say that's the biggest
thing
yeah the only thing i would add to that
is
keeping a really firm grasp on your why
like why it is that we're doing it
basically we like you dave we believe
that everything that we have financial
abilities
material possessions all those are
things that have been given to us they
aren't things that we've earned um and
so being good stewards and being
responsible stewards of the resources
god has given us um
starting off uh to build a foundation to
be able to do that is what we were
really really excited about
these guys are fun i know they're great
what a man that's awesome was it hard to
see your friends doing all the things
having all the things and you guys were
like nope we're trying to trying to pay
off this debt at times it would
definitely be difficult uh so with my
job in the military i travel quite a bit
and dave you are probably familiar with
this the military is not the best when
it comes to financial responsibility
telling a military co-worker that you
don't have an amex card is kind of like
saying i'm from outer space and i'm here
to help you
and uh so anytime we would travel it's
like hey we're going to centurion lounge
and i'd be like uh sorry i can't can't
get into that i'd be like why not do you
lose your card um and i'd be like well i
don't have one and then uh
i would go spend uh spend the time at
the terminal eating my leftover food
rather than rather than going to all the
restaurants so doing that over and over
and over again does eventually wear on
you but uh you also begin to embrace it
as well yeah yeah you start to take it
on as a brand that's right
i'll take no payments as a flex over
having a name
i agree with that i will say the card is
metal which is kind of cool but that's
all right i like that a little tougher
to cut up
that is true i have to get the two the
tin snips out yeah
i had to do that one time i had a big
old scissors and that guy brings me that
metal card out and i'm like oh man
making this hard chainsaw yeah i think
amex has probably did that because of me
i'll hey you should definitely take
credit for that they're trying to keep
me from cutting them up i believe
i'm sure i'm sure it was that a matter
of fact i'm positive yeah
you guys are awesome i'm so proud of you
well done who are your biggest
cheerleaders
yeah so we have been really blessed to
just have a lot of family and friends
that have been really supportive of us
and um like the lifestyle that we've
chosen to to live a couple specifics
that stand out we have our friends ryan
and brittany here um and they're also
dave ramsey plan holders they're holding
our kids or our kid and their kid
um and then also david's younger brother
stephen is also a big ramsey follower
and we've talked to both couples just
about our journey um and stephen
actually
and his wife jess they lead financial
peace classes
so they're very invested in good
resources to chat with so yeah very cool
very cool well very well done you guys
again very proud of you and uh you're in
a rare situation that's why we call you
weird just very very well done well
we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you that is the next
chapter in your story for sure that's
where you're headed um we're also going
to give you a a card for a one-year
membership to ramsey plus which puts you
into financial peace university and into
every dollar for a year uh if you guys
don't want to use it it's a good great
thing to give away get somebody else
started same thing with the total money
makeover absolutely and uh the gift card
for this and one year membership to that
plus the total money makeover plus the
baby steps millionaire all right david
and sarah bring up your little guy here
nathaniel is with us 187 000 paid off in
two years count it down let's hear a
debt free scream
three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's
fun
i love it i love it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at
five two two five
this is the ramsey show manuel is with
us in san antonio hey manuel how are you
i'm doing good dave and yourself better
than i deserve how can we help excellent
okay here's the scenario my daughter
who's going to graduate later on this
month from high school she has the
opportunity to attend either one of two
universities
university a for 88 000 total and
university b for a total of 208 000.
she wants to go of course to university
b
how do we explain and or convince her
that university a is the better option
okay what is she studying
she wants to study uh to become either
biology or chemistry major and then
pursue a medical degree
okay
um
do either one of these you have any
actual data that more people get into
med school
from either one of these universities
it's about the same
you have actual data or that's a guess
no no no we looked at the we looked at
the acceptance rates into medical
schools from both of these universities
so her attending the more expensive does
not help her get into med school
it doesn't increase the probability no
okay what's her reasoning for going to
the more expensive school
it's away from home
um there it is
there's the underlying issue
so how far away from
it wait a minute so the first thing i
would say to her is um okay if you're
going to be a medical doctor you have to
use critical thinking skills
okay right and so basically what we're
saying is these two schools have the
same acceptance rate
and so you are not paying a dime more
to go
to the uh to to for education
your only reasoning is you want to spend
an extra hundred and forty thousand
dollars or whatever this comes at 100
over a hundred thousand dollars you want
to spend an extra hundred thousand
dollars to live away from home
good point
yeah
and so that that's uh
so
this is not about a discussion about
education this is a discussion of do i
am i willing to pay for
you to live away from home
yeah not am i willing to pay for
you know if you went out on your own and
just weren't going to school and you
graduated from college high school and
went got a job
uh and went out on your own
uh i'm not paying for that
that's like your job because you're like
being an adult and stuff right
right and so if there's an if there's
another good reason i mean we can
discuss it i don't mind
asking a series of questions uh i assume
you're paying for this
yes we are paying for this okay how much
money do you have saved up
well we have enough saved up for the
first the
for university a at 88 000
but we don't we do not have enough saved
up to go the extra 120 000 to the 208
000. yeah so you can cash flow
university a yes okay yes yes yes the
answer is yes but not cash flow
university b
there have to be other options there
okay
well there's yet another reason um
i don't want you guys i don't want you
in student loan debt
exactly yeah does she have any skin in
the game here
it feels like she has no concept of how
much money this actually is at 18.
um
initially i thought she had the concept
but recently after our discussion uh
i don't think she does because
it
um she insists on wanting to go to
university b
and it's like well we can't afford it
and it's like
that just caused a shutdown in the
conversation
well we can't afford it but also i think
we just need to talk through the
reasoning of what's going on here okay
right um i i love you and i want what's
best for you
hey i don't want you in debt
because it's not best for you b i want
you to be able to live your dream i'm
not trying to tell you to not live your
dream in terms of going to med school
but there's no difference between these
two on going to med school
and um
and so really all we're paying for is
for you to live away from home and we
don't have the money for that
and so honey i'm just sorry as i can be
it's just a horrible it's a horrible
thing to be you
you know you're going to get your
college paid for but not the one you
wanted to go to
uh and you're not going to get to move
away from home in order to do that and
so
unless you figure out a way to pay for
it if you figure out a way to pay for it
and by the way if you paying for it is
you taking out student loans
i'm not going to give you the 88 000.
i'm not going to subsidize your
stupidity
oh good point that i didn't even think
about it to approach it from that
perspective yeah and so i you know and
at the end of the day i love you i've
got your best interest at heart i have a
hundred thousand dollars almost laying
here to help you do this to live your
dream and i'm willing to put all of that
towards you because you're my daughter i
love you more than life itself but i'm
not going to participate in things that
bring you that don't bring you good
results
now if the other school had a an
acceptance rate that was 5x
school b did of school a right then i'm
gonna start scratching around trying to
find scholarships i'm going to have her
work an extra job i'm going to have
you work in an extra job you know if we
can get her into med school 5x times
um
you know five times more likely then we
can talk about trying to make that
happen
but so far i don't hear any value
for school b and what you've presented
to us
other than she gets to live away from
home whoopty dupty
yeah
now
for more information she is a really
smart cookie and she's got i would hope
she is or she's trying to get into med
school
exactly and she's gotten tons of
scholarships and that's why these
numbers are quote unquote as low as they
are
but yeah they're still
this is post this is net of scholarships
yes yeah exactly
wow exactly so
um
it's incredible what she's accomplished
but these are very these are both
expensive schools then
yes sir they are yeah yeah but again
we're willing to go with
school a because we got the cash flow
for it can't go to school b
like you said we're not going to fund
her to
live away from home yeah
and honey if you'll go out the driveway
you will notice that there aren't too
bentley sitting there
because your mom and i can't afford them
you will notice your mom does not have a
400 000 diamond on her hand
because we can't afford it
right
and so you know money is finite we're
not in congress
good point sir you know and so i mean
this is just a values lesson
and um
you know but i think underneath all of
this and i would really hesitate to play
the card but underneath all of this at
the end of the day is
um
i i love you so much that i'm just going
to make you do what's smart for you
because it's my money
okay and you know i really wouldn't say
that if i could possibly avoid it
instead i would try to reason i would
try to persuade i would ask questions i
would talk it through get her to come to
the conclusion i'm really just paying to
live away from home because that's
really the net net of what we're talking
about here and uh we want you to live
this dream but if you live your dream in
an improper way it becomes a nightmare
yeah okay i'm not going to provide any
more than i'm going to let you spend
this money on cocaine i'm also not going
to let you spend this money on something
else that brings you harm
right
and reminder that med school is still on
the horizon which is a whole another
beast to tackle financially yeah yeah
exactly financially as another visa
we're gonna have to tackle together four
years down the road and so we gotta have
a long-term vision here we have to have
a long-term game plan and part of this
is an immaturity going i just want to
live away from home well that's not
worth 120 thousand dollars i'm sorry
yeah yeah i'll tell you what uh hang on
i'm going to have kelly pick up we're
going to give you a promo code i think
we've got them for the borrowed future
documentary do we okay or we can get you
one i think if not and you guys watch
that together with her you your wife and
her watch that
watch the documentary it will blow her
mind and yours
it's all about the epic failure of the
student loan crisis there's a dock in
there that's almost a million dollars in
debt
and orthodontist in the doctor i'll
bring you to tears and he's crying it'll
make you cry when you watch him it's
unbelievable
yeah borrowed future just won um number
one webby yeah long-form documentary
very cool
this is the ramsay chat
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
george campbell ramsey personality host
of the ramsey podcast the fine print on
ramsey networks is my co-host today we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships we're glad you're with us
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five thank you for being part of
the program melissa is in new in jersey
city new jersey hi melissa how are you
hi dave hi george thank you so much for
taking my calls and honor to speak with
you today youtube mike
thank you my question is my dad passed
away a few months ago he was your
typical i know he was your typical
everyday millionaire had a net worth of
about 1.3 wow after i i know after i
split that with my siblings obviously my
share will be a third of that one of the
things he left is an annuity and i'm
just not sure what to do
with my share of the annuity i don't
know if i'm supposed to cash it out or
roll it over or just like i don't even
know what to do with an annuity that's
my question you are the one of the
beneficiaries on the annuity i assume
yes sir okay i would just take my money
okay and then do with it wherever you
are in the baby steps you don't want you
don't need an annuity you don't want
money in an annuity at your age unless
you're in a very unusual situation how
much money is this
uh that's about 42. the annuity is only
about 42 000 out of the 1.3 yeah where
are you in the baby steps
um well
let's see i guess i'm four five and six
i've been
contributing 15 percent into
fully funding my retirement um with this
inheritance from my dad i'll put away a
big chunk for my kids
for their college and then the rest i i
guess put towards my house
you're gonna use it you're gonna use
this 42 on five or six and the same with
the rest of it
is the 42 before the split with the
three of you
that is before the split okay oh so
you're only getting fifteen twenty
thousand dollars okay
of the annuity yeah okay okay yeah
definitely definitely take the money
just use that probably towards the kids
college or wherever it doesn't matter
it's free money you don't have any
income tax on it you don't have any uh
penalties on it uh you don't have
anything on it and i'm so sorry for the
loss of your dad
so sorry what a horrible thing to go
through
brian's with us in chicago hey brian
welcome to the ramsay show
hello how are you great man what's up
well i'm divorced i've been divorced for
about five years
and i'm currently paying and for these
five years i've been paying my ex-wife
spousal support payments of about 2100 a
month
and
that was based on my income at the time
of a hundred and ten thousand
but
now
my income is only sixty thousand
due to
uh
a lot of coded uh damage to my business
and so forth and not able to make as
much money
so
i wanted to seek a
adjustment to the spousal support
payments
and it's kind of up in the air how much
it could be adjusted because it's up to
the judge
and uh
you know if we were getting divorced
today
based on my income
i would only owe her about 600 a month
but
when you seek a modification
they don't necessarily apply that
that uh
same principle they leave it up to the
judge and how much he feels it should be
adjusted
based on the change of circumstances
how can we help today
well
in the discussions of trying to get this
modified
my wife has floated the idea of she'd be
willing to take a
one-time buyout
so
like i'm scheduled to pay her for life
or until she gets remarried or
you know maybe when i retire it could be
adjusted but
she's willing to
take a buyout
um of about fifty thousand dollars
and
i'd be
pretty much a one and done payment
and would not ower anymore
but
due to my financial situation i don't
have that money the only way i could get
it is to take it out of my ira
but
i mean age 60
and i've only got about 70 000 in an ira
how old is she so
she's 54. yeah
no you can't afford to do it
well like i said unless i take it out of
the i can't afford to do it if you take
it out of your ira you're gonna get
charged a penalty of 10
plus your tax rate you're borrowing
money at 35 or 40 percent interest
to buy her out that's not a good deal
well i don't i don't think there's a a
penalty because it's 59 and a half you
can oh that's true
okay so you're just going to pay your
tax rate but no i'm not going to clean
out your right yeah i don't know
okay number do you don't have a
financial advisor do you
well i do and i talked to him and um
he
wasn't totally against the idea because
when you compare that wasn't what i was
asking what i need him to do is i need
him to do a net present value
calculation for you
on 2100 a month for 20 years
yeah and what is that going to come out
that's
thousand dollar 24
five thousand dollars a year
for 20 years yeah 50 grand is probably
not a bad offer
right i mean it would really
you know help me out because
there's no signs that she's going to get
remarried or anything right now and i
could be paying her indefinitely for
many many years and
that's a tremendous strain on my
finances to pay her yeah what are you
doing to get your business back
well you know i've i've done all sorts
of marketing and advertising i've done
some
networking and
you know online stuff and it's just very
difficult uh it hasn't hasn't been
working so i'm really struggling okay i
want your
financial advisor to do a net present
value calculation on this
and tell you what your rate of return is
because there's a thing called a
discounted
value or in other words a stream of
payments is not worth the total
25 000 for 10 years is not worth 250 000
but it might be worth 50 000
okay and uh it probably is
it probably is that's probably a very
low discount rate or high discount rate
and so um
then you can have your your financial
advisor explain that to you and run the
run the calculation they've said on net
present value
and i think it's going to be north of 50
000 so i think that's going to make this
a good deal now what you've got to do
then is you have to take the 2100 a
month that you don't have anymore as a
bill
and you have to get down and dirty about
rebuilding this nest egg asap
yeah george yeah i mean what i'm saying
here is you can see what the adjustment
is but i don't want you to limit your
income because you now have this new
payment where you go i don't want to
make any more because they're going to
adjust it again and so i'd rather you
get this thing come up and do a dave
saying and see if we can fix this thing
once and for all instead of paying this
for life i like i like being rid of the
bill and her she's the ex
both of these are good things
and um
i like every bit of that and so it's not
a
bad thing i just want to make sure the
calculation is right and i can't do it
in my head right now but i'm thinking
what i am doing in my head is leading me
to north of 50. so god that's a big
alimony payment yeah
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is
one of my
is my not one of my he is my co-host
today thank you i don't have multiple
co-hosts we have one and you is it we've
got multiple personalities but hopefully
not in this room
that's the key
i've always had multiple personalities
and then i approved it by getting them
so there you go
uh it's one of the best times of the
year here at ramsey we're giving away up
to three thousand dollars during our
ramsey cash giveaway we're discounting
our best-selling books for only ten
dollars each george what's the last
thing you got for 10 bucks oh you know
probably some pad thai
some what some pad thai i got some pad
thai gotta take out meal from a thai
place nearby oh yeah
it's under 10 bucks it was just about
yeah okay you know
that's about that's what i budget for is
mostly i buy things for food
to eat
i'm trying to think of an item that i
purchased that i was like this is worth
ten dollars to me
you know i'm pretty frugal i'm trying to
think what that might be
yeah i you what's the last thing you
bought for ten dollars that's a great
question no idea what does dave ramsey
spend ten dollars on i have no idea i it
would have to be something
i mean something silly like you know
buying a soft drink or something i mean
it's just like you can't get anything
for 10 bucks but you can get books for
10 bucks really in today's day and age
our books for 10 bucks uh you need to
spend 22 dollars to go the movie 15 for
pizza ten dollars for
almost
two and a half gallons of gas
that said
that's real scary
it's not even worth putting the thing
into top oh man ten dollars i'm done and
that's why i got the electric car down
that's it well yeah that cost you more
than ten dollars that's true so
uh
hey ten bucks you can spend you can get
the total money makeover you can get
most of our best-selling books they're
on sale right now
at
ramseysolutions.com don't forget to
enter the ramsey cash giveaway travis is
with us in indianapolis hi travis
welcome to the ramsey show
good afternoon mr ramsey mr campbell how
are you gentlemen doing this afternoon
great brother how can we help
well first of all i just want to say on
behalf of me and my wife that your
program uh your
financial university has been a blessing
to us
god has used your program to be a
blessing in our lives and my wife i i
have to say this if you ever need a new
personality for your program she will be
excellent she she does radiation
and she is she just a beautiful person
beautiful personality and she i mean we
watch your we youtube your episodes so
she she loves your programming so
see she just heard on the background she
said i love you dave
well we appreciate it this is awesome
very cool how can we help you guys today
sir
well sir i was calling because
we're at step 3b as you call it where
we're saving down payment on a house
okay
and uh i'm 43 my wife will be 39 this
year i'll be 43 tomorrow
and um
right now we have about i would say up
close to 20 000 to save for our down
payment we got 13 000 in our emergency
fund
and uh the reason why i'm
calling this is that
um
i
i have some concerns about
because we haven't been saving for our
retirement
but we're still saving for our down
payment and considering our age
should we move that snowball that we
accumulated throughout our debt and move
it to move part of it to retirement
while saving part of it for our um
down payment for our home number one and
number two where do we put that savings
for our down payment do we put that on
top of our
uh emergency fund or do we put that in a
separate account altogether
great questions i like to separate them
personally because i don't want to get
them all mixed up and all of a sudden
the house down payment becomes part of
the emergency fund so i like to just
separate them having a different
high-yield savings account or money
market savings account that's fine and
to your other point you guys at your age
43 and 39 it's a valid question should
we start investing while saving up the
down payment and there's a few ways to
go about 3b some people they start
investing 15 while saving up down
payments some people split the
difference maybe invest up to the match
from your employer while setting up the
down payment and some people do zero
investing and go all in on the down
payment it sounds like in your case
you're getting a little antsy doing
nothing in retirement right now correct
yeah that's what it sounds like and so i
think the whole point is um
you know you can decide if you want to
go ahead and buy a house with 20 000
down uh you're going to end up probably
with pmi in that case private mortgage
insurance because you're not putting
down 20
but um you know on a first-time home
purchase we don't tell people you know
we just warn you about pmi but we don't
yell at you for not putting down a full
20
second home you should sit on your tail
until you have 20 percent i mean you
know because you should avoid pmi but
when you're trying to save up and scrape
up and you guys have been working this
diligently uh if you want to go and buy
with 20 000 down if it'll get you in the
house i don't know if it will or not i
don't know what we're looking at here uh
but uh if you want to continue to say we
tell people not to not to do zero
retirement between three and baby step
three and baby step four to not get
stuck there at 3b more than three years
at zero so uh i mean it can be three and
a half but i mean i don't want you
saving for a down payment for 10 years
and not doing retirement so that that's
the point of the whole thing so hey
thanks for calling we appreciate you
joining us our question today comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsey to get the best deal today's
question comes from austin in oklahoma
i'm a real estate agent and i opened up
an s corp this year for my business my
questions is in regard to tithing should
i be tithing off of the s corp gross
revenue or off the amount of my paycheck
minus the escort business expenses
well scripture says to tithe on your net
increase in deuteronomy
your net increase would be your net
profit in business
and subs or not you have a net profit
whether you have a sole proprietorship
an llc a sub s all three of them have
gross revenue minus expenses equals net
profit
and your ti you would tithe on your net
profit because that's your taxable
income if you want to get the technical
mathematical answer
now
you know
if you hold some money back in the s
corp uh for retained earnings which you
probably don't need to do in this case
i'm not sure you need an s corp as a
real estate agent i'm not sure that was
a good move
uh you can certainly meet with your tax
advisor to find out but i'm questioning
whether that's smart
or not um
but if you um an llc might have been
better but i'm not sure you even need
either one you could do you can do
whatever you want to do but um
there's no extra write-offs for having
an llc or an s-corp because it's 100
pass-through
so anyway all that to say i tithe on my
taxable net income
uh that's the technical answer because i
tithe on my net
increase
before i pay taxes
what my net increase is my net profits
out of ramsey and that that's what we
use around here and if i don't take it
home i don't tithe on it if i leave it
in the business
for retained earnings i don't tithe on
it you can if you want i don't care
there's not listen you can split hairs
on on giving and tithing 43 000
different ways god is not mad at you
he loves you
he wants you to have the principle of
being a giver because he's a giver and
he wants you to be like him
when you say you're christ-like
or a follower of god
then you would you would do you know
he's a giver and you want to model
giving that's the main thing you want to
do and build in some kind of process
where there's a standard
regular rhythm of giving
yeah one of my favorite lessons is
outrageous generosity inside of
financial peace university and you talk
about this issue of you know splitting
the tithes and splitting the hairs and
everyone wants to have an argument and
it really comes down to the heart are
you a generous giver that's what it
comes down to and uh i think austin's
got a great heart about this he's just
wanting to get a little bit of that
nitty gritty and it's a good question
but i like the idea of just going what
is the net profit what is the net income
that's what we're going to
tithe off of if you want to give more
than 10 percent of your net profit
you're welcome to but that's not the
definition of a tithe no extra jewels on
the crown in heaven for that i mean you
know tithing off the gross diving off
the net i mean there's all kinds of
scriptural indications off the net
your gross revenues you might not have a
10 margin even
you might have profits of 3
that's possible
and so um i we tithed off a net increase
straight out of deuteronomy but again
i'm not a legalist about it god god's
crazy about me he's crazy about you i
give because my loving father says it's
the best way to live
is to be a giver this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
washington post is reporting that
fidelity investments
with its quarterly retirement analysis
has discovered the same thing that we
already knew
from the ramsey study of millionaires
done a few years back the largest study
of millionaires ever done the title is
of the article is move over crypto a
record number of workers are becoming
millionaires with their boring 401ks and
iras i love to hear this news the more
boring the more excited i get as an
actual investment strategy so here's
what it says
meet the newly minted millionaires next
door they didn't put all their money
into microsoft type stock that made them
rich they didn't take a chance on
speculating in crypto with its crazy
volatility or start a business that they
sold to some billionaire no these are
government workers civil servants
educators military folks managers
co-workers clocking in just like you
and many never earn six figure salaries
which we found in our millionaire study
one-third never had a six-figure
household income in a single working
year and so in its quarterly retirement
analysis fidelity reported that the
number of iras and 401k millionaires hit
an all-time high
that's impressive
there it is and not shocking 401k
millionaires by translation they had
over a million dollars in their 401k
uh they may or may not be actual
millionaires depending on how much debt
they have but uh because you're you're
an actual millionaire is what you own
minus what you owe
is your net worth your assets minus your
liabilities but assuming that they don't
have a bunch of other debt running
around they've got over a million in
their 401k they very likely are
millionaires and that's what we found we
found that the
typical millionaire uh it took them 12
to 15 years to get there
uh 89
did not
inherit the money that made them a
millionaire
did not 9 out of 10 did not that's
actual facts not your broke
brother-in-law who votes left-wing's
opinion
this is actual facts by actual airtight
research
okay
so
89 did not inherit the money that made
them a millionaire and we can actually
prove that with the largest study of
millionaires ever done now having said
that then
we say take toys the average is 12 to 15
years to get there we had two primary
components
to their net worth that caused them to
be get their first one to five million
dollars of net worth
one of those was a paid for home which
we found that the average millionaire
pays off their home in 11 years and the
other is their retirement account and so
when you add those things together when
you've got a paid for home and you've
invested 15 percent of your household
income into 401ks and iras it's amazing
how quickly you get there in the span of
your lifetime it's a blip and uh 79 of
millionaires in our research reach
millionaire status through their
employer-sponsored retirement plans so
this is not a theory it's uh pretty
simple guys
pretty simple uh and it is kind of like
the uh
like the article says it's a bit boring
there's really nothing uh no nothing you
get to brag about too there's no
adrenaline rush yeah you're brag you
know you're playing golf or you're
fishing with your buddies you don't get
to brag and say you did something really
brilliant all you did was just steadily
invest
and pay off your house
then i can't watch crypto over the
weekend 24 7 go up and down up and down
which bitcoin just had another cry a
crash no i know i'm sorry to hurt your
feelings dave
oh
i hate it when i'm right
do you not really no sarcasm
i sensed a little bit of that i actually
don't want anybody to lose money no i'm
not wishing for someone to get hurt
that's not that is the truth but it's
the crypto bros who think dave's out of
touch and they have been wearing me out
too so giving me a hard time
like i'm an idiot all over social media
because you know once you join the
crypto bandwagon you're like oh yeah
you know it's just it's like you've we
talked about this at the building wealth
event dave the people who are into
crypto are really into crypto they're
obsessed they're trying to sell all
their buddies on crypto and so we came
to the conclusion that cryptocurrency is
just mary kay for young men
but you don't get the pink cadillac
that's upsetting no pink cadillac maybe
in the metaverse they have a digital
version oh a virtual car you can get an
nft of a cadillac yeah you get a picture
of it you don't really have a catalog
well it's a virtual i don't know but you
don't really have one i'm just saying
virtual means not really the next thing
dave this is inviting virtually send my
wife flowers on the anniversary i don't
get anything i'm just saying she's not
gonna like this it's not gonna be a
happy day at ramsay okay i virtually
sent you flowers darling that means i
almost did it yeah i think the next
trend is going to be nft timeshares it's
a sense of ownership of a sense of
ownership
in the metaverse
you buy the timeshare
so we can both live next to snoop dogg
for one weekend at a time
this is not a far future dave i think
i'm a i'm a fortune teller oh
this is a redundancy redundancy
department
we're losing our minds
oh we're gonna get
[Applause]
an nft time share a sense of ownership
of a sense of ownership that's how that
works uh that is what the timeshare
people tell you you have a sense of
ownership which means you don't really
have ownership
but you kind of can get a whiff of it
yes a whiff i like that whiff
oh man
this is the culture oh this is what
we're up against dave lord jesus help us
oh you're going to do a nft timeshare
next door to snoop dogg i lose brain
cells every time i read headlines like
that well if you were next door to snoop
dogg
that's true can you get secondhand smoke
in the metaverse i'm gonna google that
can i get virtual
secondhand
that is a google search waiting to
happen
oh
what a time to be alive did you ever
think in your lifetime this would be a
reality because you've seen a lot of
stupid stuff in your day
over 30 years but it's getting out of
control even for you hey man i had i
mean no no i didn't have any idea this
is um
i i i actually didn't think the internet
was gonna work so
you were one of those
you went out of this is a fad it's like
you want to spend five thousand dollars
and build a website
what this is when it was first starting
with dial-up
right 14-4 hookup right
[Laughter]
i remember those days i wore out those
aol free trials dave you got that
internet
yeah i got that internet
and you had to either use the phone or
use the internet see i'm not that
exactly that young like your facts yeah
if you could fax stuff i walked up where
there was email
yeah man when i got in the real estate
business in 1978 we had these things
called fax machines
electronic realty associates yeah we
would send over this magic machine black
and white pictures of a listing in
another city
and it would print off took it about
four minutes to print one page
and uh it was an electronic and people
were buying real estate based off of
that
no they would they would agree to come
look at that piece of real estate with
you they did they were not dumb enough
to buy it off of that that's what's
happening dumb enough to buy it off of
that happened later
and they're coming from other cities
where they're so desperate to buy a
house i haven't even seen it i'll buy it
sight unseen no inspection no appraisal
don't care hundred thousand over asking
yeah yeah i'm gonna i'm just in a
bidding war
oh we've lost our minds
uh yeah should they teach critical
thinking still in school is that there's
no class on that right no we don't teach
thinking anywhere in the in the united
states it's we don't think anymore
uh you see we used to have like
arguments and debates because we didn't
have google to solve it i don't have a
good fight now because somebody google's
the answer it's me he's talking about me
you and rachel are fighting and i go
guys it was 2018.
we were having fun arguing why'd you
have to go and ruin it
because rachel and i do have fun arguing
so
if you want to be a newly minted
millionaire according to this article it
is backing up the details that are in
the book baby steps millionaires and in
the study that is outlined in the back
of the book
baby steps millionaires now if you want
to be a billionaire it's a different
formula
you will not become a billionaire with
your 401k
it's mathematically impossible
but
a billion
is 1 000 million
that's a lot of millions so just in case
you were wondering you're 1 000th of a
billionaire
when you're a millionaire wow you're
just a peon you're not even close at
that point yeah you're just a peon but
you can have a great life as a
millionaire you don't need to be a
billionaire that's a good greater life
than if you don't
there it is perspective that's what we
needed there we go thank you for using
your critical thinking skills
you still have a few brain cells left
dave turns out i i'm worried about
this uh sense of ownership of a sense of
ownership next to snoop dogg with
second-hand virtual smoke i'm just
worried about this whole this whole line
of thinking george has got me upset well
the only way to make money there is if
you're the one selling it so get to
selling some nfts dave i'm gonna have to
hard pass a hard pass there you go this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the ramsey show
david is with us in rock springs wyoming
hi david how are you
doing well how about yourself better
than i deserve what's up
uh so i'm about 40 grand in debt i'm on
was on baby step two
i have about 15 of that in collections
between credit cards and medical bills i
own a truck i want a motorcycle
i'm wondering
if i should attack the stuff in
collections first
or the stuff that i got current first
are you paying payments on the things in
collections
uh i am not i just recently started the
job uh i've put about nine grand towards
getting current on
things that things that didn't go in
collections yet yeah good um
i've been asking i've been asking for
proof of debt
uh you know these things in writing but
uh waiting to hear back yeah
uh what kind of debt is the 15 000 worth
that is in collections
it's about
five different credit cards ranging from
a thousand dollars to five thousand
dollars and then uh medical bill at
about 2500. and how long have it been
since you paid on them
oh it's been it's been a year okay a lot
of work for over a year all right what
we usually recommend is that you do two
debt snowballs
that snowball number one is the things
you are making payments on
not the 15 000. okay so you list those
things the car the motorcycle whatever
smallest to largest
and you're telling me you've got about
25 000 of that
yes what's your income
uh
a new job but it's gonna be probably
about 90 to 100. okay and you're single
yes sir okay all right so making a
hundred thousand how fast do you pay off
25 000.
months is what i'm hoping
to have this whole there you go i
started at 50 i was hoping for one year
uh
had a couple wrenches thrown in it had a
truck stolen and found out i have to
move for this new job
okay but so
so six months from now six or seven
months from now you will have plowed
through your baby step one
and you do that smallest to largest
right george yes and then the motorcycle
could you sell that is it worth anything
man
it's uh
it's going to hurt me i can't do that
for my sanity i can't
what kind of what kind of bikers
uh harley ultra classic
okay and uh what's it worth
it is worth probably
twelve thousand okay
uh i owe about i think i owe about nine
on it all right well i'd start on i
would start without selling it then but
i'm with george you could step up and do
that at some point you may choose to do
that later we'll leave that up to you
okay
now once your debt snowball the first 25
000 smallest largest is cleared
you're starting to see the point now you
don't have any payments
yep okay now when you don't have any
payments
then we're going to take
big chunks of money and start saving now
we're going to list the 15 000 and you
said it's like five or six different
debts right
yes sir i'm going to list those smallest
to largest i'm going to call the small
one what is the smallest one
uh
it's probably
hundred dollars okay i'm going to call
them anything under a thousand i'm just
going to get verification of the amount
in writing and send them a check
okay and so if you call them up and they
say it's 500 504 say send me an email
for that
as a final payment and i will pay it
this week okay no electronic access to
your checking account
now if you if you think it's five or six
hundred dollars and you call them up and
it's fifteen hundred dollars
because they've added a bunch of
collections fees and late charges and
other stuff then you go uh we want to
settle this for 500 what you originally
owed
right and you begin to begin a
negotiation and argument
with brain damaged people which will
take a while
okay yep because when you're dealing
with credit card collectors you're
dealing people couldn't get a good job
so you're stuck with them all right but
you got to work your way through it
because you owe the money so we're gonna
keep arguing with it until we get it
settled down to close to the original
amount owed or a little less
uh they will negotiate down on a year
old debt believe me
especially that medical debt too yeah
that one you should be able to negotiate
down and if they go hey is that 2500
willing to take 1200 do it
that's right
every part-time job in every case
what are we doing no access to the
checking account of course and get
everything in writing
that's the key here
but this is gonna be a part-time job for
you i mean this is gonna be a little
fight to the finish but once you're done
with that man you're never gonna look
back you're never gonna touch debt again
and the reason we pay off the other 25
000 first is it gives you more money
since you don't have any payments after
that to be able to attack the stuff
that's in collections
the stuff that's in collections feels
like it's more urgent because it's
behind but you're not paying payments on
it so you get no cash flow benefit when
you clear it you just cleared it but
when you pay off the motorcycle you get
a cash flow benefit because you're on
the payment anymore yeah it helps you
move forward in the thing so we knock
out the things with payments first and
then we go do the ones that are in
collections and the good news is you're
gonna be done with all of it
within a year
you'll be done in a year
but you're going to live on beans and
rice rice and beans
and that's if you keep the motorcycle
that's right i just like accelerating
any plan with that is painful but
clearly that motorcycle is going to
cause him more pain to get rid of than
the debt payoff so
that's your choice yep danny's with us
in new york hi danny welcome to the
ramsay show
hi dave how you doing thanks for taking
my call appreciate it sure how can we
help uh
i've been watching lots of your videos
and uh i have a high school senior who's
uh looking to go to a school for
physical therapy
and i've watched several videos about
the student debt uh crisis and all that
um my wife and i have saved up enough to
send him to his undergrad
he's looking to go to this a private
university for his physical therapy
doctor program as a six year program
what me and my wife feel is that this
entire process has been very rushed it
was a very last-minute decision
to attend this university and has left
him kind of with no other choices
um
how could i in your opinion how could i
explain it to him in a way that he
understands how it will affect
his future having to take out student
loans for his doctorate degree
which could probably amass around 130 to
140 000
yeah
without him resenting me without him
resenting me
saying that you couldn't go away or i
didn't let him go it's not that i don't
want him to go away because he's a great
student great kid no issues i believe
he'll probably be very successful at it
um but there are cheaper alternatives
yeah where i literally pay for it in
time i'll tell you how many people ask
where your physical therapist went to
school
none yeah i heard you say that too
nobody
why does he want to do the doctorate
program
you want to be a pt you have to get a
doctorate now okay yeah so the
particular university that he's been
accepted to offered him basically like a
forty percent scholarship
uh forty percent of too much is still
too much
you know i i agree with that yeah so
here's the thing i'm gonna look i'm
gonna put my arm around him and say look
here's the thing
where you go to school to be a pt and
live your dream doesn't matter
overpaying for your dream is gonna turn
it into a nightmare going into debt for
your dream is gonna turn your dream into
a nightmare paying double or triple to
become a pt
at one place versus paying one-third to
be at another place is asinine
it's ridiculous
because where you went to school
99.9
of the jobs don't give a rip
the only people that care are the snobby
people that went to those schools that
you play golf with they're the only ones
that care where you went to school and
they don't pay you any money
right they're not a customer and they're
not a boss
it's a flex that's what it is at that
point so i'm not doing that what i would
do is sit down with them and we'll gift
you a promo code to watch borrow the
future because i know you're in on this
but it doesn't sound like he's aware and
so we got to make him aware of what this
whole reality of the situation is so 88
minutes of your time kelly will pick up
we'll get you a promo code for that sit
down and watch that with them have a
discussion here's the thing there's
three things you get when you go to
school an education
an experience
and the prestige of where you went to
school the experience and the prestige
are worth zero don't play don't pay 200
000 a year to play beer pong that's a
dumb butt move
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
we help people build wealth
do work that they love
and create
actual amazing relationships open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five jennifer is with us in dallas
texas hi jennifer welcome to the ramsey
show
hi dave hi george pleasure to speak with
both of you you too what's up
hi so i have an ira that was from a past
job i rolled over into its own account
so my question is should i move that
money into my 401k where i'm currently
investing and putting my 15
or leave it in that separate ira account
i would just leave it in that ira
account okay okay even though no money
is going into it correct but it is
sitting there in good mutual funds
correct
yes it is okay if it's in good mutual
funds i would just leave it alone you've
got more control of it there i know we
never recommend you move
uh old ira money into new our old 401k
money into new 401ks instead put it out
in an individual retirement account you
can pick the same mutual funds if you
want or better ones and you've got
better access and better control
uh and it'll it will grow at exactly the
same rate or a better rate than it would
if you moved it inside the 401k georgia
is exactly right joel is with us in
cleveland ohio hey joel what's
what's going on dave up
i'm kind of a new uh listener um so
fun to give you a call so i'm getting
married in three weeks congratulations
thank you very very much
my fiancee have been living together for
the last year
we've we've tried different budgets
we've we've tried different ways
different
different websites nothing seems to
quite work we kind of end up just
a race to zero we've got a uh
combined income of about a hundred
thousand dollars
i've got about five thousand in credit
card debt she's got about three thousand
in credit card debt
um
we've got 000 savings and i've got about
20 000 in mutual funds
okay car debt any car debt
no no car debt student loan
so she's got about 20
000 in student loans okay
all right
cool well i do not and um
typically there's two things that cause
people to not be able to stick to a
budget
one is uh that they're using a wrong
technique which we can help you with
two is
they're not really committed to the idea
in other words if you write it down on
paper and have no intention of actually
doing what you wrote down
then guess what you're not going to do
what you wrote down
yeah since combining you know you know
combined like a bank
i just feel like we've had less control
and it's i guess it's
harder to pay for two than pay for one
and it just seems like a lot quicker to
zero than it used to be
this is extra confusing i mean if you've
got multiple incomes coming in you
should only have more there versus less
but we recommend a zero-based budget and
i don't know if you've checked out every
dollar it doesn't sound like you have
that's our budgeting tool and i will
gift that to you guys as a wedding
present uh including ramsay plus you'll
have access to all the videos inside of
financial peace but once you start your
every dollar budget it's super easy we
want to list out all of your income and
then we're going to list out all of your
expenses and when you subscribe to that
particular month
and when you subtract the expenses from
the income it should equal zero meaning
you've assigned every single dollar a
job
we don't want any of your dollars
unemployed and once you do that and then
by the way you have to stick to it and
actually track it and go how much money
do we have for food when we go grocery
shopping
then we're going to stick to that budget
and that's how you're going to get that
control but i can write down a workout
plan every week dave and if i never work
out i'll never get in shape yeah so so
get you assign every dollar a mission
every dollar a name that's why we call
the app every dollar both of you look at
that
before the month begins it's unique to
each month because every month is
different
okay
okay and then once you've assigned every
dollar both of you look at it both of
you make changes until every dollar has
a name
no extra slush money laying around every
dollar is assigned all the income you
have coming in net that month to work
with is assigned to something then it's
it's it's assigned to something both of
you agree with the assignments you agree
with the mission
and then you pinky swear and spit shake
this becomes a freaking contract
that says if we're not going to spend
more than
x number of dollars on restaurants then
by god stay home don't go to the
restaurant
you're contracting with each other we're
not going to spend more than this on
clothes this month i don't care if the
purse is on sale
we agreed to make that
extra trip to target we agreed that this
is what we were going to spend don't lie
to me
that's what you're saying to each other
you're contracting you have to make it a
very serious relational commitment
that's why both of you need a vote in
the formation of the thing
because otherwise you're bossing her
around or she's bossing you around
becomes a weapon but instead you're as a
couple saying our goals are x and the
best way to achieve our goals is this
list of expenditures
this month and we're not going to do
something
other than that unless something really
nasty bad happens and then we have to
come back together and together decide
on how we're going to change our budget
before we do it you don't come home from
target you don't come home from the
grocery store you don't come home from
happy hour and go well honey look what i
did that's not cute
that's childish
and that's the thing where i'm talking
about you committing to
sticking to the plan but laying out the
technique that the technique is every
dollar has an assignment as george said
that's called a zero-based budget the
two of you coming together
and agreeing that this is what we're
going to do that's the technique now
typically we always say joel you said
you're new to this stuff we always tell
folks typically a married couple one of
you is more of a nerd that's into the
details and one of you is more of a free
spirit
that's less into the details and isn't
going to think this is fun and the nerd
thinks doing the budget is like great
fun
correct okay i'm the nerd
more frustrated yeah that would be
normal that the nerd calls and asks this
question
okay how do we do a budget free spirits
don't ask this question she's at target
right now yeah
so there we go
that's we figured it out yeah she's
getting her nails done right now so uh
but you know in my house i'm the nerd my
wife's the free spirit and so same as at
your house joel so what we have to do is
this nerds need free spirits in their
life so they have a life
free spirits need nerds in their life so
they don't retire and have to eat alpo
so that you need each other if if two
people just like get married one's
unnecessary
so we need to be we need each other you
need to be working off each other's
strengths both of you have a vote this
is a coming together of a value system
it's not you bossing her around her
bossing you around you're not the boss
of me and this might be married two to
three months to get dialed in so don't
give up if the first one you go oh we
couldn't do it let's give up we can't do
a budget stick to it and kelly will pick
up we'll gift you guys a year of ramsay
plus which includes every dollar our
premium budgeting tool let us know how
it goes and go all the way through the
financial peace class it's included in
that we just gave you a great expensive
wedding gift
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
how many of you are stressed out about
your retirement savings these days
should you be really freaking out
probably not
but we all got a little drama queen
inside of us right yeah me too
and that's why you gotta have somebody
in your corner to help you with your
investing not to do it for you but to
help talk you off the ledge when things
are going down a little bit
someone to walk with you talk with you
teach you and that way you don't jump in
and out of the market at exactly the
wrong times which is actually what your
emotion will have you do your emotions
will get greedy and cause you to buy
when markets up
and it'll cause you to sell when the
market's down and this is exactly the
opposite of what you should be doing so
instead you should be investing and just
staying in there hang in there hang in
there that's why we recommend a smart
investor pro they're investing
professionals that we've carefully
vetted and they work with you one-on-one
to make a retirement plan you can stick
with go to ramseysolutions.com
smart vester to find a list of smart
vester pros in your area and one of them
will sit down with you and help with
your retirement plan guide you through
the ups and downs ramsay solutions dot
com slash
smart vester
lionel is with us in midland texas hi
lionel how are you
good good how about you randy show
better than we deserve sir how can we
help awesome awesome i had a
uh financial question um i'm 31 years
old and i was considering uh opening my
own business i'm thinking about a
laundromat i just wanted to you know ask
y'all to see if
it was the right timing uh or something
like that
why a laundromat
uh because it's a passive income um
i know the beginning of the of the
business i'm sure the first couple years
i'm gonna have to be really uh
it's gonna take up my the majority of my
time but after a little while you know i
wanna
uh
live a free life you know for for uh
you know
i don't want to be too tight up yeah
uh you're not you're going to hate this
because you've been lied to
it's not a passive income
uh the stupid washing machines break and
somebody has to fix them somebody's got
to go down there and get the quarters
somebody's got to manage the change
machine somebody's got to make sure the
place isn't being thieved all the time
correct so it is actually running a
business it's not a passive income a
passive income is you sit and money
comes into your mailbox this is not a
passive income
yes sir so um if you want to work at it
you can probably make some money the
laundromats are they make good money do
you have the money to buy one and set it
all up
um
i'm thinking of i'm not going to use my
personal money i would want to
ask for
loans uh and uh do it with that i have
projected i've turned some numbers down
and it would take uh roughly about two
hundred thousand uh to start one from uh
from scratch okay
well i i can tell you what i would do i
wouldn't do it
and here's what here's why
eighty percent of the small businesses
fail
in the first five years in north america
according according to the small
business administration
the ones that fail 80 of them
say the number one reason for their
failure
is cash flow problems
now let me define where cash flow
problems come from from having counseled
small business people now
for
uh about two decades
cash flow problems are not paying your
taxes properly and getting behind with
the irs
not paying your sales taxes properly and
getting behind with the state department
of revenue
and having to pay payments on 200 000
worth of washing machines with quarters
that's going to kill you
okay you're you've increased the risk of
failure
a hundredfold when you start talking
about borrowing 200 000 to open a
laundromat
uh and the numbers that you've crunched
i can tell you from having run
businesses for 30 years the numbers that
i crunch are normally wrong
on a brand new venture we don't know
what we don't know
and you're not going to be your
estimates aren't going to be that close
and the rule of thumb is this
it's going to take twice as long as you
think cost twice as much as you think
and it's gonna and you're not the
exception these are the three rules
and so uh no i would never go 200 000 in
debt to open a laundromat in any economy
ever
because your your risk of bankruptcy is
very very high
please don't do this
please save your money start a business
of some kind for cash out of your garage
start small make some profit reinvest
make some more profit reinvest grow your
business gradually but no you should not
go 200 000 in debt and think this
laundromat is going to run itself you've
done made two sets of assumptions here
that are both going to cause you to walk
into a nightmare i'm begging you not to
do this i think i know where this is
coming from dave because i've seen these
videos on tick tock and they're all
these entrepreneurial types saying hey
you should start a vending machine
business and a laundromat business and
here's how easy the money is stuff has
popped back it's pop back up dave but
it's on tick though so it's on tick tock
so it's cool exactly it's cool to be
stupid yes and so i think that i think
lionel's got a good heart i love that he
has an entrepreneurial spirit but he has
been lied to from the videos he's seen
about how easy it is to make this money
and some of the most heartbreaking stuff
has been around forever i know man i saw
that same stuff i was 20 years old 40
years ago
let me tell you what happened to me 40
years ago i almost bought i was gonna
pay cash but i almost bought
you couldn't die a car wash no no i
almost bought a hundred of those
uh
air compressors that you put at the
market and put a quarter in to get you
pay for air oh at the gas station when
they very first came out i was there
when they very first came out and i
almost bought 100 of them and put them
out
and uh i got sidetracked doing real
estate deals and and left that to the
side but this was the same crap yeah it
was coming it was all get rich quick
stuff lots of income you got to be an
entrepreneur entrepreneurs where all the
money is and all this stuff instead of
what a real entrepreneur does which
actually invents something or actually
grow a business but yeah and i really
just never could quite get past the
humor of paying for air
and that's the other reason i didn't do
it um and yet i have put a quarter in
one of those things and aired up a tire
timer too
but um
like someone became a millionaire off
your recorder
four times in my life i did that
probably but yeah
it's uh but yeah vending machines let me
ask you let me just tell you i know
people who own vending machine routes
that actually do it they don't have a
tick tock account i can promise you that
it's freaking hard work yeah and a lot
of those machines produce almost zip and
then you got to move them and find
another location for them and then you
got to move them again and then people
kick them in and tear them up and man
it's just it's
nothing is as easy as it sounds and
certainly nothing is as easy as it
sounds with stupid butt tick-tock but
then no one's going to buy my online
course as to how you can start this
passive income business with your
laundromat it's not passive at all
when someone says passive income and you
have to work at it by definition it's
not passive george
oh my god well some of the most
heartbreaking calls we get are the ones
where they started a business they took
out a whole bunch of money and loans and
then the business failed and now they
have the heartbreak on top of the
business not failing they now still owe
two hundred thousand dollars yeah paying
payments on your failure that'll piss
you off twice a day yeah that's
heartbreaking so don't do this move at
the speed of cash check out all of our
resources that the entree leadership
team has get off a tick tock for
business advice
lord jesus
unbelievable i mean this is cats chasing
lasers and i'm glad you didn't have tick
tock when you were younger dave because
you would have started about a thousand
business i would have fallen for every
one of those things i almost bought the
air machines i really did do that i'm
that dumb
i am that you could have been an air
machine mogul by now but instead you're
running this little business wow missed
opportunity there you go that's what
happens changing lives when you don't
when you don't hold one one quarter one
flat tire at a time that's right we'll
pump you up
man wow
oh wow let me tell you meeting the
people that come to our entree
leadership event i had nothing
i knew i mean i know there's a get rich
thing happening out there right now a
vibe
happening especially among your
20-somethings and you guys you guys
think it's like the first time that this
stuff has come up that's what's so funny
vending machines are the new thing
all the old trends come back around but
you know with fashion with business it's
all coming back dave
if you thought it died
let me tell you so yeah so apparently
the phrase so the catch phrase for get
rich quick is passive income that's it
ding ding i'll buy your online course
i've redefined the term improperly to
mean easy money
you can make eat money easy money you
don't have to work for a living that's
right that's what that's what that's the
new american dream that's what
tick-tockers mean by passive income i am
learning so much today i'm here to
educate and inspire yeah no people the
real definition of passive income is an
actual investment that just sends you a
check and you don't have to go down and
get the quarters out of the air pump oh
my god this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today sarah is with us in
maryland sarah it says on my screen
you're debt-free congratulations
hi thank you so much dave yes
way to go how much did you pay off
i paid off forty three thousand dollars
good for you and how long did that take
about a year and five months all right
way to go and your range of income
during that time
well i uh started out at zero i had to
make my first payment out of my very
meager savings and then i started my job
later that month at 87 000 and now i
make 92. cool what do you do for a
living
i work for the government i'm a cyber
planner oh nice
and your debt the 43 000 what was it
that was all student loans dave
so you came out of school and a year and
a half later jumped on it and it's done
is that the story
yeah
way to go what made you decide to jump
on it so hard i i didn't want to turn
out like my parents and you know 55
still paying on their student loans i i
just wanted something different for
myself yeah
and what made you think you could
actually do this
a really big part of it is thanks to my
boyfriend and his parents uh they
followed your plan to get out of their
debt and they taught me everything they
knew and i was like hey
i think i can do this
that's cool i'm impressed way to go
boyfriend and parents excellent job how
old are you
i'm 25. okay so you're not waiting on
the government to forgive your student
loans huh
i thought about it and i was like you
know what no way let me just like i want
to sleep at night let me just get this
done list
done you're close enough to dc to know
it's never going to happen that's what
it is
there we go there's the real answer
you're amazing i love it well
congratulations sarah i'm proud of you
thank you so much how's it
feel it is incredible you know like a
huge weight off my shoulders 10 000 of
that 43 was all interest that
accumulated and to just not have that
anymore it just it's crazy it's so great
that's so fun good for you
good for you you got to also kind of
feel like
accomplished like confident
it's
i don't know i like to stay humble but i
really have to hype myself up sometimes
to see you like you know i i did this
yeah i actually did this there's a
dignity to it
yeah i
i didn't think i really could but i i
was determined and that determination
carried me well this is your chance to
brag right here on this call and we're
proud of you we're we're here to brag on
you you we think you're amazing way to
go 25 year old paid off your debt you
didn't have to have somebody do it for
you you threw your shoulders back and
knocked it out way to go kiddo pop pop i
love it so excellent what kind of
sacrifices did you make along this uh
journey sarah
well i certainly learned a lot about
delayed gratification
uh i you know i had to push certain
things off to the next month i didn't
always buy the newest video game or
i didn't always go to the movies with my
friends um i put about a full paycheck
and a little bit more every month to my
student loans
and you know i could have been wasting
that on like a new car or a better
apartment yeah you come out of college
with a great income you think well now
is my chance to really show everyone all
my success
exactly that's that is a lot a lot of
people did but you know i i just kept it
like really down low i
liked what i have and i stuck with it
so i'm guessing your boyfriend and his
parents were cheering you on what other
cheerleaders did you have
uh
well my sister definitely
but other than my sister it was pretty
much just my boyfriend and his parents
they they were there every step of the
way and i would send them the
screenshots of my payments so that they
could you know tell me how proud they
were and i could i could feel good about
it
good for you
well done
i love it
excellent excellent job okay now that
you've done it what do you tell people
the key to getting out of debt is
determination and sharing rent
absolutely if you have an apartment by
yourself and you have a spare room
you're wasting money
you know just get someone else in that
spare room share your apartment
how did you screen your roommate to make
sure crazy didn't come in there
well my roommates my boyfriend
so there's that that's one method of
screening
exactly right you know hopefully he's
not crazy
we waited a couple years you know i got
the full made sure he's
and good a ramsay kid too so yeah there
you go no he's a financial piece kid
he's not
he doesn't want his credit score he has
no credit card no credit score
wow good good for you way to go sarah
excellent job we got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you uh
best-selling book and that's the next
chapter in your story also we're going
to send you a one-year membership to uh
financial peace university in every
dollar and ramsey plus and on top of
that we're gonna send you a copy of the
total money makeover to give away
and uh you've already lived a lot of
this and uh your boyfriend certainly
knows a bunch of it but you guys can
enjoy the going through the class
together hopefully as you're married and
and uh move on to the next phases of
your life congratulations we're very
proud of you all right sarah in maryland
paid off 43 000 in one year and five
months making zero to 87 to 92
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two
one
i've got free
[Music]
[Applause]
oh it's done right there
wow she wasn't gonna wait on no one to
pay off her debt and live her life she
said she wants to sleep at night
if i thought they would listen to them
i would send
2 000 of those debt-free screams from 25
year olds that we've done
to washington so they would know that
the debt that student loans don't have
to be forgiven um
we're telling people that they can never
get out instead tell them they can get
out quit stealing their hope
with politics
then we'd be okay but instead we have to
go oh you're pitiful you can't make it
without me i'm in the government
how much are they gonna get their vote
however yeah how else am i gonna get
your vote if i don't buy it
so oh and and i have to run you know but
she's got dignity yeah i mean she has
the power
she's unstoppable controlling her life
not waiting on someone else to control
her life that's so cool
megan is with us megan is in minneapolis
hi megan how are you
uh hi thank you for taking my call sure
what's up
um so i just started a business this
year i have a part-time job right now in
that same industry on the side
i'm on baby steps four five and seven
and i'm wondering now that i'm done with
my school
is it a horrible idea for me to quit
this part-time job to make more room for
my kids this summer or should i focus on
building
my business
or make more room to build my business
or should i keep my job until i get more
clients for my business are you married
i am yep what does your husband make
so he makes about 35 years okay and what
do you make at your
job
so my part-time job i make thirteen
hundred dollars a month i haven't done
much time right and what do you make on
your business
i'm eleven hundred dollars a month
okay
so you're going to cut your income by 25
when you do this
unless you agree unless you increase
your business size right
yes yes
okay
and
i'm the only reason why i ask or that
i'm kind of i would really like to cut
this off is because
so for the past couple years i've been
doing full-time work full-time school
you know i had my daughter i didn't take
a semester off you know to have her
things like this and i'm
i think i'm officially i'm just kind of
maybe
hustled out a little bit right now at
the moment how many hours a week are you
working
so i i mean right now i'm working about
like 45 50 hours a week so i mean
honestly not like
super
overworking it on i mean if i will be
honest it's more so my business is more
um kind of like night weekend
and my part-time job is more like in the
in the day
i just don't the 50 hours a week to make
28 grand isn't worth it even between
your part-time job and the side hustle
i'd get both of these things up
really
yeah you might consider a different
career one where you make some money
if you can't get your business going
that's not enough to live off of but i'd
get your business rolling
what i would do if you like the business
i'd get it up and running and get it
running where you can make some good
money on it at 40 hours a week and get
the husband's normal working hours and
you know i think that's it i think i
think george is onto something here and
if you can't do that then you probably
ought to look at a different career
because you're not really making much
money that's what it comes down to you
wouldn't be so dead i'm tired if you're
making a hundred and thirty thousand
instead of thirty thousand
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day ephesians 6 11
put on the full armor of god
so that you can take your stand against
the devil's schemes
lou holtz said
if what you did yesterday still looks
big to you
you haven't done much today
i like that you gotta love coach lou
he's the best coach lou's spoken for us
a couple times at andre leadership and
he is always a standing ovation always
gets the highest speaker marks and he is
the highest quality of human being so
much integrity absolutely amazing man
absolutely fun to hang out with and just
a great guy
so we love coach lou around here all
right miranda is with us miranda is in
raleigh north carolina how are you
miranda
i'm good how about you better than i
deserve how can we help
okay we are on my husband and i are on
baby step number two um and we have two
debts left to pay off one is a credit
card of 7 700 and then we have a car
that we owe 23 on
and my question was do we need to think
about selling the car
and getting a cheaper one
what's the car worth if you sold it
today
um it's a honda accord i looked it up on
kelley blue book and i think it's about
27. okay we just called it last year
all right so you clear that debt and
have 4 000 left over could you get a
beater car for now for four four two
grand until this debt's cleaned up and
then upgrade
i mean i guess we could the other car
that we we do have one other car that my
husband drives is uh um
2012.
um
and i'm i mean i guess we could
what's your household
income after tax is 80 000. okay
the rule of thumb that we use miranda is
two things okay
if you like the car which it sounds like
you do
if you can be 100
debt free
except your home
in two years
car and everything
and the total of all of your vehicles
value is less than half your annual
income that way you don't have too much
tied up in things that are going down in
value
then you can keep the car or you should
financially it makes sense to keep the
car is the best way of saying it but if
you have
let's say that you make 80 000 a year
and you got 70 thousand dollars tied up
in cars you got too much going down in
value right
yeah okay no our other car is only worse
than i know i know
i know but i'm just saying as an example
or let's say that you owed a lot more
debt than this and the 23 000 debt being
gone would make a huge difference
uh let's say you had let's say you had
another 40 000 in student loan debt well
you might need to get rid of the car so
that you can get rid of student loan
debt right
but in your case i think if you like the
car and you guys will fight to be 100
debt free in under two years you would
meet both of the general financial
mathematical guidelines that we have to
keep the car
okay
okay
and i think we would be willing to do
that we just started your program in
january and we've paid off um
almost 15 000 in debt in those few
months well if you stay on that track
you would be debt debt-free in one more
year
yeah exactly you're talking three grand
a month you were just making something
yeah if you keep if you keep going
fifteen thousand that's twenty five
hundred a month fifteen thousand to six
months whatever yeah three two three
thousand dollars a month you'll knock
this out in about a year and if you do
that then it makes sense
if you like the car to keep the car but
as george is pointing out if you get rid
of the car you'll be dead free in 20
minutes here
but then you're going to turn around
probably and save up and buy another car
within a year because you don't want to
have that four thousand dollar car for
long
that's a get by car that's not a car we
keep
uh so
i'm probably keeping it if i'm in your
shoes based on what you're telling me
that makes sense yeah absolutely alan is
with us alan is in riverside california
how are you alan
i'm doing well on yourself better than i
deserve how can we help
so thank you for taking my call um dave
and george um so i am 24 years old um
i'm getting married on saturday yeah
yeah thank you thank you so um so just
jumping to the point my um grandma
um told me that she's been saving um
saving bonds for me since i was uh
essentially born
and
she so she had them all locked away so
she showed me that i'm burying on a big
in a big envelope um every single month
um since i was born until now
we went online to like the treasury
website whatever that we call the bank
to see how much it's worth
um and so far it's it's about 14 000
for all the saving bonds that she
accumulated over the years how sweet um
my question is
since um some of them have not
matured enough because i was like doing
the research because honestly i don't i
don't really know know much about these
since like just about a week ago i found
out um learned about these so
um my question is should i leave them in
no um until like all of them are mature
should i take them out should i okay
cash them out
okay that's the mathematical answer
then the proper financial answer is
apply them to wherever you and your new
wife are on the baby steps where are you
guys yes um we
okay so
um we have no debt and we already have
our emergency fund so we're saving up
for our three to six months of living
expenses great that's what this will go
towards
okay um should we
just put all towards here should we save
some for our house or no
you should follow the baby steps how
much is three to six months of expenses
for you guys do you know yet
um right now we we have a house and that
we're renting and it's seventeen hundred
dollars a month
um
and that's literally
literally it
um well there's stuff like food
electricity gas insurance
it's going to be literally like 3 500 a
month and so you need an emergency fund
of 15 000 bucks
and if you have nothing saved then
that's fine you use this money and you
have your emergency fund voila if not
then you need to um
and if you already have more than that
then you've got some towards your down
payment on the house right yeah and so
after that emergency fund is done that's
where you start looking at your next
goal and i'd take a pause keep renting
as a newlywed couple get to know your
new spouse and then you can start going
all right do we want to start saving up
that down payment in our area where do
we want to live uh do we have our
incomes we have jobs that are in place
and then you can start investing 15 and
you're on your way man 20 24 years old
that's a good place to be and if you
tell your grandmother that you use this
money towards the down payment on a
house or towards uh having a rainy day
fund she'll be proud in either case and
that will be the truth grandma said it's
gonna rain yeah you gotta have a rainy
day it's awesome that's where grandma
got that god bless grandma yeah so that
you're you're right on track doing that
but yeah you just follow right up those
baby steps that we teach alan and um it
doesn't change because it was a gift the
only thing you want to do is you always
when someone's giving you a gift
especially your grandma
uh you want to do something or even an
inheritance you want to do something
that honors
the person that gave it to you and that
they would be proud that you did that
with it and usually if you're doing
smart things like investing or paying
off debt or buying a house or something
like that you know grandpa and grandma
are generally going to be very proud of
that kind of thing yeah it's not
frivolous and i'd love to give you guys
a wedding gift it's this saturday that's
fun so kelly's going to pick up we'll
give you guys ramsay plus which includes
financial peace university every dollar
plus
go through these with your uh now fiance
soon to be wife and man it's gonna
change the game for your marriage give
you guys language to talk about money
give you guys some goals that you can
set together and i'm telling you that's
one of the best things you can do as you
start this marriage
yeah so make sure to jump in when you
get back from the honeymoon you guys get
settled in jump into the financial peace
videos
online there and we're going to give you
all of that as our gift and it'll get
you guys started together and we'll walk
you right up the same baby steps we were
just using here right now
and so it's a good point dave don't
watch it on the honeymoon that's that's
not fun well there's something more
exciting i i would claim financial peace
university is an amazing course
romantic it is not okay that's a good
point just saying okay so it's not has
nothing to do with that so
that's good enjoy yourselves hope the
wedding goes well congrats there you go
so hang on kelly we'll pick up we'll get
you signed up for it those nine lessons
will change your life son if you'll go
through them it's good stuff change mine
very good stuff all right george good
hour good hours today well done thank
you james and ben and kelly and zach in
the booth thank you for all your hard
work i am dave ramsey your host we will
be back with you before you know it in
the meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace christ jesus
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
you